hallo ich meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen zu einem watson
video ich hoffe das passt alles von der
videoqualität und von der audioqualität
weil ich wieder ein wenig improvisiert
habe ich war ja meine kamera micro immer
noch in der bearbeitung ist wie kaputt
war und keine ahnung ich hoffe das passt
so alles ihr wolltet das ja dass ich im
kontakt mal einfach meine apps vorstelle
ich hab das damals bank mache weil sich
sehr viel verändert
auch weil ja dieses neue firmware update
wird mal irgendwann kam und so weit
alles m
ich hoffe wirklich jetzt klappt von der
qualität dass sie das erkennen kann wenn
ich nur an gehe ich hab ja nicht so ein
gutes objektiv also schon gut aber nicht
so für nahaufnahmen deswegen halte ich
das ganze jetzt mal so ich hab schon
halb muskelkater aber sozusagen hilfe
anhalt noch mal an und zwar also erst
mal hier und ich hab halt ein iphone 5
nicht dieses 51 oder 50 das mega cool
aussieht könnte so bei apple hinlegen
das haben wir müssen endlich ganz cool
sein finde ich ja sind schon viele
kratzer drin die stars das ist mein
hintergrund der sehr sehr schlicht
es ist einfach nur seinen sondern seine
tapete halt irgendwie mag ich irgendwie
so schlicht rhythmus an gemacht damit
ihr als hier nicht sehen mit wem ich so
schreibe dies dass genau hier fertig
machen also ich glaube wir sollten das
eigentlich wissen wie man ein iphone
bedient wenn ihr euch so etwas antut
eigentlich müssen wir das wissen
mein coach kann der code aber egal wir
fangen erst mal standard app halt
nachrichten dies das nutze ich
eigentlich nahezu nie nur meine eltern
das ist immer so die schreiben wenn ihr
mir schreiben und schreiben die sp
whatsapp whatsapp schreiben die erste
what's up und dann schreiben die man
nachrichten das ist richtig komisch
die nennt man immer so ja der trotzdem
ich lese aber nachrichten liest er
bestimmt so richtig kommt irgendwie auch
froh ihn schlagen nachrichten app ist
prophylaxe termin zahnarzt ach guck mal
hier schon 18 uhr holte also hier haben
wir dann da ließ das ist eine sehr coole
apps steht du hast heute frei hier ist
an der kalender also mit meinem geplant
ist dass das schiff zum beispiel heute
termin sonntag um 15 uhr muss mitmachen
da kann man sich so als möglicher
eintragen hier dass ein kumpel von mir
geburtstag hat das habe ich jetzt aber
kann
und da wo ich zum beispiel frontlineshop
bestellen wieder kontakt kann man jetzt
ein paar sachen it plan oder her doch
einfach im schulalltag so etwas wie da
habe ich zum beispiel deutsch latein
habe ich da auch und da muss ich sie zum
beispiel fett aufnehmen dann hab ich da
den prophylaxe terminen am sonntag schon
anmerken dass die da habe die stars also
damit plan ich so ein bisschen mehr
leben das ist ganz cool
so passt das überhaupt so pessimistisch
passen fotos ganz klar halt einfach
fotos kamera um vorwärts zu machen dann
haben wir hier youtube ist natürlich
muss für youtuber empfohlene videos ok
ach ja weil ich im flugmodus bin aber
halt wir können halt jeder sehen konnte
und eingestehen noch ganz leicht ist der
coole empfinde ich die beste youtube app
so ist einfach die originale halt finde
ich dann haben wir notizen durch ein
paar sachen eintrage wie auch keine
ahnung so hatte ich mir noch kaufen muss
ich widersprechen soja rasierklingen
shampoo die stars und so was halt
eigentlich einfach notizen halten oder
ich versuche die ganze zeit die bessere
einstellung ich könnte ja auch mal
einfach
ratet mal so vielleicht so besser dann
haben wir hier die meistgenutzte app von
mir wo man halt einfach seine zeit
schreiben kann man ist in gruppen man
kann halt gut sachen planen wenn man
sagt ja heute fußball dann bis in seiner
gruppe drinnen ja nicht hätte für mich
kein richtiger mensch hat die sie auch
schon gesagt wie gibt es menschen die
sich jetzt installieren
also ja keiner whatsapp messenger
facebook hat facebook messenger ich hab
auch hier noch eine facebook-app aber
ich finde diese messe einfach an sich
die push benachrichtigungen kommt
schnell an man kann besser videos und
filme verwenden auch videos und filmen
videos und bilder versenden und so was
alles facebook messenger nicht einfach
cooler digg.com sword habe ich als
letztes nachgeschaut
da kann ich das hier ihnen gesehen
zurück ich kam einfach nicht es ist halt
ganz cooles im offenen wort stadtteil
ich bin dort im flugmodus ganz einfach
mal hallo eingeben und dann steht hier
also ist ein online wörterbuch ist
eigentlich das beste wörterbuch für
nichtig punkt 17
dann kommen wir hier in meinen ordner
brno dies aber den app store wo man sich
halt apps downloaden kann ist der place
toren anderen anderen geräten sport1
halt sportnachrichten gmail einfach auf
meinem einem eine mail kacke da halt für
kräfte gmail.com mir facts gesendet
werden
skype habe ich sie macht die
benachrichtigung so sieht das aus ich
nehme übrigens kein an wenn die da in
ihm einen profi raus finden solltet weil
dieser kontrakt auf fischl der dm die
paysafecard verkauft euch deinen humor
ein wildes ein fake sam zum leader
erkennen und er ist sonne richtig
richtig coole apps ich zeige euch noch
ein paar von indien richtig gut wer
keine verbindungen aber finde ich
richtig cool gestaltet so was halt katze
im fernsehen läuft
amazon hat in sachen bestellen aktien
der compass videos wetter game center
kontakte itunes versprachen sleep cycle
alles so apple apps aus dem sleep cycle
das ist ganz cool du kannst zum beispiel
urteil einstellen ich gebe da zum
beispiel bei uns immer 6 45 1 und dann
weg der dich irgendwann zwischen 6 und
15 und 6 45
und zwar genau dann wenn du gerade am
wach ist ein bisschen da ist man total
fit morgens immer bei mir klappt es
trotzdem passt die hier auch alle sap
labs außer ketchup für youtube-filme
wenn man die aufnehmen will das habe ich
aufwuchs film manchmal macht als ich mir
beispielsweise spaghetti gemacht habe
oder so und deutsche bahn navigator
einfach waren diese scheiß die gefahren
der deutschen bahn obwohl das erstellen
weil die ema verspätung haben dann haben
wir hier den kalender also dann nutzt
deswegen ist der eu dies ist ein
bisschen unnötig der manchmal drin in
dem ordner texas ganz cool ich kann dann
englischen text einfach fotografieren
nein kann ich jetzt hier einfach so
einen englischen text von der basis
dieser tolle hintergrund den ich gemacht
haben in ihrem text fotografieren ist
jetzt kein text tut mir leid
und dann immer setzt er mir den halt das
ganz cool wenn ich ihnen meine
hausaufgaben konto ist ganz cool kann
man fotos bearbeiten
also ein titel daraufhin n-tv ist auch
eigentlich ganz cool kann man n tv
haltet nachrichten bekomme ich auch
immer hier so leid nachrichten da steht
jetzt werden bei instagram welchen
freunden fotos von mir gefallen und
hamburger sv verpflichtete trainer
slomka
nein geld einfach erklärt sich von
selbst
wohin ist einfach wenn ich zum beispiel
irgendwo in dortmund war ich letztens
und da war es halt so ich will wollten
halt weißen gehen ich einfach wohin
angemacht und dann kann man halt
auswählen kann man hielt essen auswählen
ich habe jetzt keine internetverbindung
aber kannst alles auswählen auch sofort
ohne helden und alles mädchen sport1
sowie sport1 nur anstatt nachrichten
halt mit radio 3 11
die hab ich ja ich hab mir die nicht
gekauft einfach so weil ich dachte so
kama sutra das geld gebrauchen sondern
einfach nur weil ich ja ich war
betrunken und wir haben gesagt wir
spielen schlagstock und der verlierer
muss ich an dem kamasutra app kaufen und
dann habe ich halt verloren der 239
gekostet denn geht nichts falsches
zeitungskiosk auch von apple und sich
nie die latics ist einfach so fitness
übungen die man auf dem spielplatz und
so machen kann autoscout24 ist halt
autos gucken tasks so was nutze ich auch
eher selten da habe ich als da dies auch
so ein kalender mäßig app und runkeeper
einfach zum laufen so dass schon der
größte ordner am gameslab bird kennt ihr
alle kennt die crash bin ich bei devil
125 mittlerweile kaká ist der ersten app
dies sowie communio aufgebaut also eine
fußballmanager abdecken lässt dann ist
man so fische fangen
sollten nicht alle kennen da kann man so
fliegen wir zum jetpack durch seine
monster welt als monster wählte ich so
eine elektro welt doodle jump sollte
auch eigentlich jeder kennen muss man so
springen die magische miesmuschel die
ich immer ein risiko
chris duell so zu fragen beantworten mit
hochs habe ich noch nie gespielt sei
aber ganz cool angeschafft als es
kostenlos war aber noch nie gespielt
minecraft muss man natürlich drauf haben
einfach nur so weit gucken wir was also
neue updates kommt und tiny wings
schreibt eine kompanie von minecraft
video von mir auf handy sehen wollt dann
kann ich das tor noch aufnehmen dann
allerdings und das ist halt auch einfach
um fliegen
so wie keeper leon wäre dann die nächste
app und zwar als wikipedia halt einfach
20 wikipedia für iphone kann man das
nennen einfach wikipedia fürs iphone
sondern der stars nach kurzen heute
damit die einstellungen dann haben wir
hier in news die nutze ich am meisten
von atv nicht spielen sondern so
dienstprogramme nutzer meisten
soundcloud musik weil ich da so
spindelegger zufolge das sage ich ganz
ehrlich seiten manager für kontrabass
alles übers handy box net einfach weil
unser lehrer auf boxen vertrauen das
mega scheiße die x box nicht gar nicht
oder können ihre sachen hochladen
die arbeitsblätter oder so beide team
ico sportwetten einfach ich hab schon
denke ich hier richtig richtig viel geld
davon twitter einfach zum zweiten komme
ich trete erst mal was ach ich hab ja
flugmodus aus geschäft kommt egal dann
mache ich das vielleicht dann habe ich
ihr safari nutze ich aber auch fast gar
nicht weil komme ich gleich zu warum
nicht und metall so privates male habe
ich auch 200 neue mails also für schule
mails und in die unis und keine ahnung
irgendwie sowas instagram habe ich halt
ich habe meine instagram instagram dot
com / laser an luca also dieser kontrast
da bin ich nicht der beschreibung könnte
mir sehr gerne folgen mir sogar
irgendwie noch 50.000 aber hinten
knacken wenn die tage dass er echt cool
also hatte ich mit botox snapshots auch
ganz cool
kann man also fotos mit versenden die
andere person aber nur für weiß nicht
drei sekunden also für ein bis zehn
sekunden sehen kann und man muss an den
finger drauf halten also man kann
screenshots davon machen aber da der
andere sieht halt wenn man es mit macht
und nsa coup zu dann haben wir hier
telefon hat zum telefon ihr das hier
sind die vier wichtigsten ist also
beides ist die bayern welt immer da
immer da unten egal welche machen
möchten werden immer der unten
facebook erklärt sich von selbst opera
ist einfach warum ich so fahre nicht
benutzers auf höhere preis nämlich finde
ich viel cooler als safari ist auch
schneller und spotify einfach zur musik
hören und ich habe zurzeit keinen
einzigen lkw
eigenen spotify com sondern ein mit
einem kumpel und ich werde mir dann
einfach wenn ich dann bald einen eigenen
spotify account habe werde ich euch die
filme 80 filme die playlisten von mir
mal online stellen dass ihm nachfolgen
könnte weil das letzte meine
lieblingsmusik video war ja so ein
bisschen an alle heute konzipiert
playlisten zeigen ja aber das ist ja
nicht mein sporty fall kommt das machte
mir nicht ab so dass ich mein handy
meine damen und herren meine apps die
ich besitze potsdamer vor und ich hoffe
euch als gefallen dass weizen kontakt
der halt wieder ein bisschen
improvisiert war schreibt mir die
kommentare was jetzt nächsten kontakt
machen sollte sieht echt gut aus
irgendwann dass ihr so ist echt geil aus
schreibt mir was ich beim nächsten
kontakt machen soll
und sonst würde ich sagen lasst einen
daumen hoch da wenn es euch gefallen hat
das wird mich auf jeden fall sehr sehr
freuen und schreibt in die kommentare
was eure lieblings apps sind ich bin
hier total überlegen die ganze herunter
hängen lassen habe schalten die
kommentare was eure lieblings apps sind
und welche von den apps ihr eventuell
auch auf eurem helden ich habt und
natürlich sage ich wünsche ihnen
wunderschönen tag macht's gut und schaum